classique disons maintenant la
découverte des traboules c'est une
particularité de la ville de lyon le mot
vient du latin il signifie passer à
travers les traboules sont donc un
véritable réseau de circulation
permettant de passer d'un immeuble à
l'autre la ville de lyon recense plus de
400 cours et rabou que le public potes
en partie la visite et stéphanie
labrousse gens comme eux
tout sert une porte est arrivé dans la
cour des voraces au coeur du quartier de
la croix rousse le centre névralgique
d'une traboules à trois ans pendant
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
évidemment ça va être la voie royale de
la résistance un lieu qu'on prêtait
aussi on leur tend les canuts les bras
chargés de soi les traboules ou un
véritable réseau de circulation
traversant les zimmer les usages c'est
simplement d'aller d'une rue à l'autre
c'est le c'est le principe même en
économisant le terrain donc on construit
en même temps quand on circule sur la
même parcelle en gagnant une place folle
de monde ça descend et à des petits
recoins on regarde puis c'est vrai que
c'est super joli
de tout temps les travaux se sont
développées à lyon au rythme de son
urbanisation à la croix-rousse ces
passages du 19e siècle au vieux lion ses
traboules du 16e on va essayer un
nouveau truc avec le pouce droit et la
fesse droite et sa soul tout le monde va
devoir faire ça dans celle ci en tout
cas pas besoin d'un guide forcément pour
traboules et d'une rue à l'autre
encore faut-il se renseigner sur les
adresses et se faire discret car ces
vieux sont évidemment habité et ici on
arrive sur une me
une cour tout à fait ravissante on se
croirait absolument à florence qui
grimpe sur cinq étages avec
un escalier qui dessert à la fois
l'immeuble qui est devant nous et par
l'intermédiaire des galeries que vous
voyez ici qui dessert l'autre immeuble
était sur la route il y aurait à lyon
400 cours des traboules
toutes sont privées et bon nombre ne
sont pas visitable car fermée
la municipalité a donc mis en place il
ya 13 ans des conventions de droit de
passage
ses propriétaires acceptent de laisser
leurs travaux le ouverte au public entre
8h du matin à 8 heures histoire à
condition que en échange de quoi la
ville leur offre l'entretien de la
traboule et puis d'autre part la ville
paye participe aux frais d'éclairage une
vingtaine de conventions sont en projet
pour permettre aux touristes de
découvrir davantage de ces lieux aussi
beau que pittoresque
déambuler dans les traboules et
s'imprégner de leur ambiance si
différentes
brest 2004 à partir